there is a new report that former
president donald trump is now actively
working to remove mitch mcconnell as the
leader of republicans in the senate now
what's funny is trump's worth that work
ethic
we learned with him as president is a
disaster so the fact that trump believes
is believed to be actively working
towards something may not really mean
very much but regardless let's talk
about uh what is being reported at this
point in time business insider reporting
trump is actively working to oust
mcconnell as the senate republican
leader now remember because republicans
don't currently control the senate mitch
is the senate minority leader rather
than the senate majority leader okay
just a just a point of clarification to
ensure that we have clarity this evening
former president donald trump
has spoken recently with republican
senators and political allies about
ousting minority leader mitch mcconnell
from leadership and is gauging whether
there's any interest among lawmakers for
a possible challenge according to the
wall street journal there appears to be
little support for such a drastic move
according to the report but trump's
actions could potentially morph into a
larger issue for the party especially as
the kentucky republican hopes to regain
the senate majority in the 2022 midterm
elections and the former president
continues to float a potential 2024 bid
so you have these two factors coming
together you have republicans want the
senate back in 22
and there doesn't seem to be much of an
appetite from the base to remove mitch
mcconnell as the leader on the other
hand donald trump is thinking about a
run in 2024
mitch mcconnell at least over the last
nine months has not been a particularly
big friend to trumpism and you have this
conflict which way are they more likely
to go
um while trump and mcconnell worked
together
to fill scores of federal court
vacancies and with conservative jurists
along with passing the tax cuts and jobs
act and other republican priorities
trump's intransigence in accepting his
election loss to now president joe biden
and the january 6 capital riot deeply
strained the relationship between the
two men that's sort of an understatement
in the sense that at every rally trump
has done recently which we've covered
just about all of them
he actively goes after mitch mcconnell
and so-called rhinos and talks about how
bad actually mitch mcconnell has been
rarely let me put a different way i
don't want to say rarely
i don't remember even a single instance
of a current or former republican
president being this hostile
to a republican senate leader
it's not even that it's rare i just
don't remember any other instance i'm
glad to be reminded of one if you're
aware of one
the article goes on to say after trump's
second senate impeachment trial for
incitement of insurrection for his role
in the riot mcconnell declined to find
the president guilty
but sharply rebuked him on the senate
floor later mcconnell said he would
support trump in 24 if he were the
nominee
but trump has not forgiven the minority
leader for his speech
trump has continued to needle mcconnell
in the press he recently took the
minority leader to task for backing the
1.2 trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure package that passed the
senate last month calling the
legislation a disgrace
trump saying quote if mitch mcconnell
was smart which we've seen no evidence
of he would use the debt ceiling card to
negotiate a good infrastructure package
um
we'll actually talk a little bit about
that on the bonus show today as well so
let's see how the base reacts i welcome
the self cannibalization or i guess you
don't have to say it's just the
cannibalization
self cannibalism well you guys know what
i mean i welcome the republican party
eating itself
so far
the base which supports trump has
certainly
cheered on trump's attacks on other
republicans at least his rallies at
rallies but a lot of those rally-goers
are confused by what's going on they
don't know you know leftists down
whatever they don't know what's going on
they would probably cheer whatever trump
says it's it's not clear they actually
are
understanding what they're doing
but
we could see a change in the interest of
the trumpian
wing of the republican party
in supporting trump's attacks on the
establishment republican party
in particular if trumpism doesn't do
well in the midterms in terms of ousting
mcconnell mcconnell was just re-elected
in 2020 he's there until 2026.
i have a difficult time thinking that
republicans will really turn on him
as long as something completely insane
isn't found in mcconnell's closet i i
actually am hoping trump succeeds at
creating chaos and hostility against
mcconnell in a more serious way among
the republican establishment i just
don't think he can do that much
um but anything he's able to do is
likely to fracture the republican party
and that's a really great thing it would
be terrible for republicans in the
upcoming midterms to be fighting each
other as much as they're fighting
democrats it would be great for
democrats for republicans to be fighting
each other it's just really not clear at
this point to what degree donald trump
can get republicans angry against other
republicans in a way that will actually
have electoral consequences i just don't
know the answer to that now this
saturday trump is doing a rally in uh
i believe it's in georgia
my plan is to cover it technology
permitting and schedule permitting uh we
will see
to what degree trump attacks republicans
and the location of this rally in
georgia is actually very important
donald donald trump we talked yesterday
just released this letter
written to officials in georgia all
republicans remember
demanding that the rightful winner of
the 2020 presidential election in
georgia be announced trump means himself
by saying that
and there's a very good chance in
particular with saturday's rally being
in georgia that trump will go really
hard
against the republicans in that state
it'll be interesting particularly in
light of the mitch mcconnell plan that
trump is developing and you know plan
may be a bit of a generous term it'll be
interesting to see to what degree the
crowd cheers trump's attacks on
republicans so that's saturday in the
meantime
tell me this find me on twitter at
deepakman and tell me this
do you really think republicans might
turn on mitch mcconnell i have a very
difficult time seeing it let me know
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video